- [Instructor] Now a related idea to
just what a bureaucracy is
in our federal government.
Another question is how
do they get influenced?
Now one idea that you might see
in many American government courses
is the idea of an iron triangle.
So an iron triangle describes
how various parties might
influence each other and what
they might do for each other.
So let's say that there is a group
that is very interested
in building more roads.
Maybe there's a group that represents
all the road contractors
in the United States,
and they would love more
highways to be built
because there'd be more business for them.
And so then that interest group,
who wants more highways to
be built, they might say,
hey, congresspeople, we
want more highways built.
The way that they try to
get favor with Congress
is through electoral support.
Now what kind of electoral
support could they give?
Well, they could donate money
to the congressmen directly.
They could donate money
to political parties.
They could try to activate the electorate
to vote for a congressperson
who favors their agenda
more than someone else.
In exchange, congresspeople
could do a few things.
They could provide more
funding to the bureaucracy
that is going to build roads,
and we just talked about that
bureaucracy in the executive branch.
That bureaucracy, not only
might they build more roads,
but if they like those interest groups,
they might lower their
regulations on them.
They might give them more contracts
as they build those roads.
Another thing that Congress could do
for the interest group is
pass friendly legislation.
So maybe pass a law that
makes it easier to build roads
in a certain part of the
country or in a certain way.
But the reason why it's
called an iron triangle,
it's not just about what
do interest groups want.
It's also what does Congress want?
What does the bureaucracy want,
and what do they get from
the other two parties?
So we already talked about how Congress
can get electoral support
from interest groups,
but what can it get from a bureaucracy?
Congress passes laws and a budget,
but a bureaucracy, for the most part,
decides how to execute on that.
And so if they are aligned with Congress,
they might execute on those laws
with a little bit more energy.
If the bureaucracy, for
one reason or another,
is not as gung ho about those laws,
they might drag their feet a little bit.
And from the bureaucracy point of view?
Well, we already talked
about how they could get
funding and political
support from Congress.
You see that on that part
of the triangle there.
What do they get from the interest groups?
Well, we already talked about
the congressional support,
which they can do by
supporting congresspeople
who might support favorable
policies for the bureaucracy.
The interest groups might be able to
directly lobby Congress, which means,
hey, we're going to meet with Congress.
We might even draft some
things for the policy agenda.
Now a related idea to an iron
triangle in interest groups
that you might also hear in
an American government course
is the notion of issue networks.
One way to think about
issue networks is they are
essentially more informal
than interest groups.
Interest groups can be
part of an issue network,
but an issue network can be, let's say,
you and I start to get really activated
about something we get on TV,
and then we start mailing
our congresspeople,
and we start blogging about it,
and we start getting a following,
and then that starts to
influence an interest group.
Or an interest group joins with us,
and then we start to send
messages to Congress.
We start to provide more
scrutiny on the bureaucracy.
Then we would be an issue network,
and as I mentioned, issue
networks might not be formal.
They might not be a formal, let's say,
lobbying group or interest group,
but they can also have
influence in the same way
that an interest group does.